it makes me wonder about the families
that will go watch their superhero
batman movie
take the children and then go wait a
minute
what this is so r-rated
what is going on there reject nation
yeah we heard about this and i really
wanted to talk about this because i find
it kind of odd
uh the batman is practically rated r
yet it's got a pg-13 rating
and i wanted to discuss this because
that's what is rated pg-13 for is being
practically rated
this is the caption set yeah i wanted to
talk about this because it just boggles
my mind and the plain and simple truth i
want to talk about a little bit of why i
think this could have set some audiences
down the road too well i think it
probably upsets some people right now as
well i think it's an interesting
discussion to actually be hats and they
can be a little bit poignant which we
will not do we're just going to make
stupid jokes the whole time but guys if
you're here take a batarang to that like
button let's dump into this alright so
here's what the batman is rated pg-13
for
and honestly like if you did not know it
was rated pg-13 if you heard a movie was
rated something for this
strong violent and disturbing content
drug content strong language these are
just words that i get afraid to say that
youtube will like hear me say that and
go demonetize it like these are words i
want my young teenager to pick up
and then here is exactly why this movie
is not rated r the very talent and some
suggestive material
let's face facts out here in the states
especially you could be strong
violent when i hear strong violent
disturbing content that's like r-rated
violence right like that's where your
mind goes i can't think of the last time
i'm sure maybe there's a version of this
that exists but i really don't know of a
pg-13 movie that was pg-13 and had
strong
violent and disturbing content
associated with it i've never heard that
before yeah and i mean it's funny to me
because you know money and and the
rating system obviously intermingle and
for my point of view i feel like they
have gotten a lot more effective in
recent years at making pg-13 movies feel
brutal and violent and it's just a
matter of literally not having blood it
boggles me a little bit but i can also
very much look like blood that's the
thing yeah yeah and then you watch you
know the trailer and you see that like
really personal looking beat down and
you're like this yeah like it would lead
to some disturbing developments and some
bloody altercation and then they say
strong language in here and i'm like
what do you mean i thought i thought we
had an f word rule here you got two
efforts in this
they say some strong language yeah
strong language is
our rating but when it says some
suggested material that means it's not
that sexual so we can get away with it
yeah yeah yeah it's gonna be very very
tastefully cropped when selena kyle and
batman finally get together a little bit
but it's not gonna be anything you can't
show your young teenager like i think
the i think the rumors of uh robert
pattinson doing zoe kravitz on the
batmobile are completely false now
i believed it until now yeah that's
right it's just been cut down a bit
they've just uh you know cg on like a
cape over them so it's appropriate for
the whole family you know it's just
funny because there's nothing more human
than sexuality it's such a such a human
thing and it's corrupting the youth it's
corrupting us it's ruining us don't let
them get interested in it super early on
but we can show them as much violent
disturbing right keep them from having
sex by inspiring them toward violence
yeah and it's it's not fair because
there's so many movies that have gotten
our ratings for things that we because
of like sexual related things we're like
guys it's not pornography
this is fine this is fine we don't need
to go written bodies are not suggestive
but what's weird me about this is
when you have a rating such as this it
makes me wonder about the families
that will go watch their superhero
batman movie
take the children to watch it
and then go wait a minute
what this is so r-rated because
the pg-13 stem be cut was it indiana
jones too or was it gremlins i can't
remember which one it was i think it
might have been temple of doom i think
it was it was it was probably like a
combination yeah close together it was
like temple of doom was like pg but it
was very violent so we're like we need
to do something about this raiding
system yeah we could do something in the
middle here's another
yeah your show hearts get ripped out
yeah 100
the following movie is rated pg so you
know when i think about what this is
like oh man this could be like the film
that stirs the debate and i'm at the
point i'm like why did you just make
this raider just go right here i think
you know you saw no tickets at this
point the first r-rated batman movie and
it looks r-rated and everything you're
saying it's r-rated for so that's what i
mean the dichotomy of it will come into
play and then there will be future
movies that get r ratings when you're
like but the batman is pg-13
yeah i'm really curious because i feel
like an r-rated batman movie is going to
happen at some point and i feel like
especially in light of films like joker
that's more and more and more likely
however i feel like we're still holding
on or at least wb whoever is still
holding on to that crossroads of like
but it's batman we can always make more
money if it's pg-13 and so i feel like
this one is gonna be one of those movies
that they probably have orchestrated to
straddle that line and yeah feel like
it's an r-rated movie but pull just
enough punches back
so that they can technically squeeze by
so ultimately i actually don't imagine
it hindering the film too much but at
the same time
but at the same time it does very much
feel like and you know we've had a
couple of trailers before this rating
was revealed it feels very much like
r-rate like they want us to get excited
for our r-rated materials well yeah i
mean a lot of the influences are heavily
david fincher serial killer movies yeah
and not one of those is pg-13
yeah it's not a fun family rom no yeah
it's like the pg-13 movies that he's
done are not his serial killer movies
for a reason hey man panic room
yeah something and then like
thematically what this movie would be
exploring especially with the you know
the complexity of what it means to be a
hero and going for the most grounded
realistic approach yeah it would make
sense to me that this would be rated r i
just think it's a really interesting
conversation like the mpa rating system
is a really weird one and like there's
this great film i saw on netflix ah ages
ago i think it's called this film is not
for your consideration something like
that this film is not yet rated yes
that's the one yeah um i i saw that this
one like netflix streaming was like
brand spanking like when it was only
crap on netflix usually and then i
watched this
and um it really exposed because no one
knew who's like rating who are the
people rating these movies and how
there's a weird infrastructure to hear
of like why are some of these rated r
and some of these aren't when it's like
this one's clearly worse yeah you do it
they due to exposure on it and you see
like the people like with uh when they
hire a pi like a lot of them are like
big time studio oh yeah
oh more controlling this there's a lot
more than decency at play with these
ratings and there's a lot of gaming of
that system and people shoot things to
be more intense than they intend them to
finally cut as because they know they'll
be asked to take stuff out so they'll
use that to their advantage which i
wonder if happened maybe here because it
does look brutal so i wonder if they
maybe shot some bloody stuff as
sacrificial lambs to get more content in
there well guys what do you think about
this how freaking strange is this to you
because this
i bet he wanted some sexual stuff and
they cut it out
when's the first batman movie with a
graphic sex scene that's what i want to
know that's what i will be surprised to
see someday
paul verhoeven's the batman
yeah ah please i want it i want it
elizabeth berkeley is barbara gordon
all right guys thanks so much for being
here uh what do you think about this
piece of news does it shock you at all
no not really like whatever you knew
this was coming people think it's a
weird one just thought they would maybe
skip this opportunity to not go right
[Music]
you